série marine le pen a dit elle ne
viendrait jamais sur un de mes plateaux
à voilà sur btp devrait jamais je tenais
là dit elle aller direct et bien les ati
il est parfait partout elle a dit alors
peut-être changera peut-être d'avis
voilà oui est-ce que vous l'auriez
invités à banon la vie et faire on l'a
vite on a envie de débattre avec tous
ses biens communs c'est parce qu'elle
parle tout le temps de démocratie
n'aurait pas lieu de parler à tout le
monde à la halle pourrait venir et
parler à tout le monde a des gens qui
regardent aussi les gens qui regardent
la voilà non mais l'international nous
regarde
il va être plus que l'appel marine le
pen malawi
vous changez pas le marigot celui que
vous allez invités marion maréchal le
pen qui va peut-être venir
il te lui sera réservé si je dis que
vous n'êtes plus dans l'émission est ce
que devenir marine le pen allait on
appelle marine le pen tout de suite le
pen c'est marine le pen il faut du
personnel mémoire de ces produits être
un petit message
[Musique]
mais là pas mon numéro elle c'est ça ma
force je numérotation marine le pen
qu'on appelle en direct y compris un
lapin pour ce coup d'essai je l'appelle
je laisse un petit message
madame le pen c'est giannina pakistanais
est ce que vous pouvez me rappeler j'ai
vu que vous deviendriez pas dans une de
mes émissions
c'est dommage parce que je voulais vous
inviter dans les boîtes il ya les 300000
bull a gagné rappelez moi mon numéro un
du s'afficher
on vous embrasse surtout bernard montiel
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment numéro de marie lopez
en fait je vous racontais l'histoire
c'est que je demande à un de mes
assistants un moment valentin le
producteur en émission je dis ce que tu
peux me passer numéro de marine mais
marine c'était quelqu'un de corée avec
m'vila - côté oui il m'a envoyé
directement le numéro de marine le pen
et jeudi l'état c'est vraiment le gros
de la région paca du oui j'y crois je
garde le numéro je vous l'aurais donné
moi c'est ma mère
[Rires]